welcome back during the pandemic
magician xavier mortimer
exploded on social media his illusions
have over 5 billion views online
and he's now taking his act to the strat
xavier welcome to the show and
congratulations on your new show
the dream maker how excited are you
hi thanks for having me it's uh it's
very exciting it's a new adventure now
and and during the panda so during the
pandemic you're tick tocks i mean
they take off and you end up partnering
with jason jarullo
how does that partnership come about um
it's just uh
i started to publish videos because we
were stuck at home and also because uh
the show was closed
so i started to do magic on social media
and i got reached out by
jason and among other uh celebrities
uh and it was it went super well we
produced like a
a bunch of tick tocks and they uh they
took off it was
an amazing experience well i'm so
excited that they have this brand new
show is there something you can do for
us now
i hate to put you on the spot but i mean
you're an incredible illusionist
incredible magician
something you can do right now on las
vegas now yeah sure uh
look it's a it's a simple thing you have
uh cards here it's my collection of deck
of cards some of these
decks are super old and from all over
the world
name a card that you like name a card
yes uh the uh the anika head of hearts
perfect now you're gonna choose one of
these dicks any dicks um i'll take that
from from the left
the bicycle one the red white and blue
bicycle uh that one yes yes
no that one yes yes no no no no next one
that one yes that one right there so
this is a regular bicycle and you can
find it anywhere
among all these decks when i receive
them when i take them
home i do one thing it's my tradition i
just turn
uh back uh one card turn over
one card in every of these they can
every of these they have a different
character
what was the card you named the eight of
hearts
what did you say eight of hearts eight
of hearts
yeah and so if you see a color you split
flipped over and
i see it i see it i see it flipped over
yeah
yeah what did you say again eight of
hearts don't you that's funny because
wow that's unbelievable how did you do
that
it's magic right it's magic yeah it's
incredible
xavier we're so excited about your new
show when does it start
uh it starts july 1st that's fantastic
thank you so much for joining us and
i mean that's just a tiny little taste
of the stuff that you do your tic tacs
are amazing
there's many illusions and you can check
out on social media we've been doing
big illusions and we're going to bring
all these illusions on stage
uh exactly you are incredible we can't
wait to see the new show thank you so
much for joining us today we appreciate
it my friend
thank you so much for having me xavier
mortimer and the dream maker debuts at
the strat july
1st it's going to be fantastic thank you
so much